Elon Musk owl's Twitter board named Soul
director and people are overreacting to
this oh my God God forbid for this guy
to do something like this Twitter said
in the Securities filing Monday that the
nine members of its board uh a former
board are no longer directors of the
confirmation of 44 billion dollar merger
musk always intended to take over as a
sole director under the terms of the
merger agreement according to the filing
the dissolution of the board was dislo
disclosed in a broader Securities filing
that spelled out other formalities as
part of the deal closing including
repayment okay great so the market
reacts oh my God he fired everybody on
the board he's the sole director this is
bad news I just sold my insurance
company uh June 27th and we had a good
sized board and when we talked to the
company that's buying it they didn't buy
10 of it they didn't buy 20 of it they
bought a hundred percent the company
when we talk to them there's no longer
the board I'm a managing director and
the board members are nicely kindly
asked hey thank you for your service
thank you for what you did but you're no
longer board member the new owner
chooses to not have that board because
that's how things like this happen but
this makes for a great headline this
makes for a great story and he's the
sole director because he owns Twitter
that's what the normal person that buys
a company does he gets to choose that he
didn't get rid of them for any reasons
he didn't fire them it's just what you
do when you buy a company Tom want to
hear a story like this what do you think
about it oh it's just piling there
everybody's piling on Elon Musk they're
just piling on trying to find a story
where there's nothing Burger there if
someday he takes Twitter public again he
will have a board of about nine people
why because the law says that under
Securities in Exchange Commission says
that you need to have a boarding
compensation committees and audit
committees and things like this but when
let's put it this way if you're out
there thinking about this and you own a
small business who's the owner you who's
your board yourself who are your
advisors maybe your spouse maybe friends
maybe family maybe Patrick David is your
one of your advisors it's just you but
if you went public the law says you have
to have a board Twitter is no longer
public and I look at this and it's just
like what Pat just said about selling
his company this is piling on this is a
nothing Burger these are people saying
oh my gosh he oused his board he didn't
oust this board they were a public
company board and when the public
company dissolves you no longer need a
very normal thing it's not it's not a
big thing it's not just normal it's
according to the legal regulations of
how you organize and tax a company but
it makes for a great headline a matter
of fact this next one's even better if
you want to hold this what you say
they're good there he goes again it lets
you and CNN will say there he goes again
can you pull up Elon Musk Q score I'd
like what I want to know is
like what is it about Elon or why
there's so much hate towards Elon is it
because he's a billionaire is it because
he trolls people is it because he's
childish it's because they the word he's
taking over the world he's is he is he
an advocate of free speech because you
know that's not what they like these
days apparently I don't know I think
freedom of speech is pretty much cool
hang on you know he's an entrepreneur
who won't toe the line and is unafraid
of you that's no no no but why do people
I understand it why maybe like big
government wouldn't like him or even big
Tech or you know competitors I'm saying
average people what is it about Elon
that pisses people off you see all these
famous people go to eBay Twitter go to
Gates
okay so go to Elan
okay go to Cuban
go to Buffett
go to Bezos
the most dis Bezos is the most disliked
by the way out of all of them and
Bezos is 38 yeah can you go over these
numbers yeah if you if you look at uh go
to Donald Trump Jr let's see what that
one says he's disliked by 53 go to Zuck
of course he's disliked by 49 almost uh
Zuck is almost disliked as much as
Donald Trump Jr is that is very very
strange go up
so Bezos was what disliked by 38 Buffett
was 17 20
uh musk was 30 click on musk 33 and
Bates Gates was 29 if you click on Gates
by the way this uh numerical like order
is it like there's a there's a reason
for it is it based on Fame is that the
highest how they're putting this no I
think it's ranked on popularity well
yeah Fame popularity uh so Bill Gates is
97 then Elon keep going just boom boom
boom boom junior junior 93 80.
tell me tell me what's your question
so what I'm saying is yeah okay so we're
using what number are you looking at
what number are you focusing on the fame
the popularity they're just likely
looking at dislike okay you're looking
at this point you're saying you you said
why do so many people dislike them so
that's the number so okay gotcha so Bill
Gates is 29 Elon go quick Tyler so we
don't take a lot you just did Elon just
did it Elon is 33 Mark Cuban 17 Buffett
is 20 uh Bezos is uh 38 Juniors 53 and
Zuck is 49. yeah not sure why Junior's
on that list however very weird that I
have Junior on that list if you had
Donald Trump on there even close to that
so how do you process this yeah that's
what I'm wondering is that uh
Zuckerberg and Bezos are way more hated
than Musk
way more hated based on these numbers
yeah yeah interesting he's but but
here's the point it's such I'm so glad
you went here because great Point you're
making to say just because politicians
and mainstream media scream at as loud
as they are about how much they dislike
this guy the average person actually
likes this guy that's my whole [ __ ]
point you're right I'm like what's with
the hate on Elon you you cannot be again
the one thing that we have to work on as
we mature in business like I was a naive
businessman I was a naive salesperson I
was a naive player in the market you
know you're not naive when it comes down
to girls there's no way you're going to
be naive when it comes on or leave my
personal life but but what I'm saying is
in we all have areas of Our Lives where
we're not naive in where you don't fall
for [ __ ] okay for example yesterday
Dylan and I were driving the car said
Dylan who do you think is going to win
the Super Bowl oh that for sure the
Eagles so tell me why the Eagles oh Dad
are you kidding me they're I'm telling
you for sure they're winning I said what
are you talking I said dad they're 7-0
maybe the Giants maybe this maybe
Minnesota but it's going to be Eagles
win the championship so that's what you
call a naive fan and then I said look in
the game of sports winning the
championship has to do with what who is
the healthiest when playoffs start it
was the hottest team in during the
playoffs hottest and healthiest wins the
Super Bowl right most likely to win hot
and healthy everyone comes down to stuff
like this you can't be naive and say why
does the media not like this guy dude
the media had a full-on monopoly on
controlling point of contact in the
narrative until this guy bought Twitter
Facebook actually has to now wake up and
say listen guy if you keep doing this
stuff of be careful because of a
disinformation stuff this guy's gonna
hurt you you know what he's trying to do
do you know what one of the things he's
trying to do can you pull up that Fox
Business article that Mario sent to us
yesterday it's a fantastic article uh
that Mario's very big on news and Wall
Street like about the five things that
Elon wants to Elon musk's five major
moves in the first week of Twitter
ownership go up let's look at the five
go up okay number one dissolving Twitter
board okay that's done he owned 100 of
it go to two two is a firing top
executive zoom in zoom in zoom in some
people are very upset about what this
guy's doing here following the closing
of his acquisition musk fired agrawal
Chief Financial Officer Ned ziegel uh
Vijay Gade Twitter's head of legal
policy trust general counsel Sean
edgette also confirmed on Twitter that
he is no longer with the company after
several hours reported he was including
this he says Thursday concluded five
years of Twitter I'm grateful for the
opportunity I've worked with such an
incredible group of people
okay great so now go to the next one go
to the next one point number three point
number three on what he did uh right
there bring bring in and look at this
one this is important bringing in Tesla
Engineers to review Twitter's code oh my
god oh
and you better believe Tesla Engineers
running a trillion dollar company they
kind of know what they're doing of
course go to number four go to number
four launching content moderation
Council moderation Council and revamping
Twitter verification this is the Eight
dollar a month thing that he told uh EOS
if you go a little bit higher
uh right I'm sorry I say higher I mean
lower yeah there you go uh Twitter will
not be an orange of the platform Twitter
will not allow anyone who was the
platform for violating Twitter rules
back on the platform until we have a
clear process for doing so which means
if some of you guys are wondering about
Trump it's not going to be happening
which will be for at least a few weeks
Twitter content moderation Council will
include Representatives with widely
Divergent views which will certainly
include the Civil Rights community and
groups who face hate field violence go
lower and show the last one which is
number five and I'll tell you what he
just tweeted the other day go to number
five Vine Revival which he wants to
bring Vine back and five million people
voted for that seventy percent want that
thing to come back here's the point Iran
said the other day which is powerful and
it's important Vinnie to you and to Adam
and to Tyler here's what he's doing
he wants to pay content creators that's
great what does it mean he wants to pick
content creators what other platform
Pace content creators hello YouTube Pace
content creators Facebook page content
let me tell you this way if this guy
starts paying content creators on
Twitter and they start making money they
have to realize he is now officially the
most hated man both in politics and in
Silicon Valley because Silicon Valley
has controlled everybody because they've
had Facebook Twitter everyone and now
this guy picked them up and then in
politics they've had to control the
narrative now they can't call this guy
and say Hey you gotta de-platform that
guy hey you got to do this you gotta
nope because he ain't playing by your
rules anymore that's why he's the most
hated guy by politicians and silicon so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]